hello everybody and welcome to this
tutorial on yet another opportunity to
come and work for the EU institutions
we have published a set of competitions
to select lawyer linguists
lawyer linguists are lawyers who can
translate legal texts into a certain
language
and with these competitions we're
looking to select loyal linguists into
six languages
you need to be able to translate into
English Spanish Lithuanian Dutch
Portuguese or Slovak
as usual we have published an
infographic on our website which
explains in a nutshell the different
steps you need to take to become a
successful candidate
the successful candidates will be listed
on the reserve list the so-called
Reserve list and this Reserve list will
be handed over to the court of justice
of the EU based in Luxembourg the court
of justice will be recruiting from this
list
in this tutorial I'm going to walk you
through the different steps to become
successful
we're talking about six competitions in
six different languages
you can only apply for one given
competition so you have to choose one to
make up your mind and choose the one
that is best fit for you you see the
number of successful candles in the
second column there they're quite
considerable so it's quite a nice
opportunity if you meet the eligibility
criteria
speaking of which it's an ad7
competition and depending on the
language you need a degree in a certain
law field so for the English language
competition you need a degree in Irish
law for the Spanish competition in
Spanish law for the Lithuanian one in
Lithuanian law for the Dutch competition
you either need a degree in Belgian law
or in Dutch law
if your degree is Belgian it should be a
Dutch language Belgian law degree
and then for Portuguese and Slovak you
need indeed a degree in Portuguese or
Slovak law for some languages
besides the Criterium of a degree
a qualification a certain qualification
can also be eligible so to find out more
about this please do read the notes of
competition carefully because everything
of course is detailedly explained in the
notice
then the language Criterion you need to
speak or Master at least three different
EU languages the first language is one
of the six competition languages
your second language must be French
why French
the judgments of the Court are drafted
in French so a large proportion of the
text to translate are to be translated
from French into different languages
hence the need for you to master French
and then the third language can be any
other language uh official language of
the EU
this is how the selection procedure
looks like everything starts of course
with an application then there's a
testing phase of course you will be
asked to send in supporting documents to
prove that you are eligible and then you
will be notified about your results
good to know is that all testing is
remote so you do not have to travel to
Luxembourg or Brussels to sit these
tests you will see these tests from home
which makes it quite easy and accessible
for you to take part in this list or in
this competition
so let's have a closer look at these
different steps
you need an epso account to apply for
any given competition if you already
have one do not create a second one but
use your existing account to apply for
this competition
if you don't have an account yet you can
easily create one on the website
you apply it through our website on the
home page you find a link to these
competitions and you can fill out your
application in any of the 24 official EU
languages
we prefer you to fill it out in your
language one so the competition language
to speed up the process but if you like
of course you can apply in any language
of the 24 official ones
you need to validate your application by
the 17th of October so you can go in and
out of your application during the
application periods but make sure you
validate it in time 17 October midday
Luxembourg time which is basically
Brussels time
once validated you will be invited to a
series of tests we first test your
reasoning skills verbal numerical and
abstract reasoning will be tested in
language one so the competition language
you see the number of questions the
duration and the scoring
you need a combined pass score of at
least 20 out of 40. so everybody who
reaches at least 20 or more is still in
the running for a place on the list of
successful candidates
I suggest you have a look at our sample
test page where we have examples of this
kind of questions available have a look
at them train this because if you you
know do this often you get better at
this kind of Reason skills tests
and then of course there will be two
translation tests translation test one
will be a test or translation from
French into the competition language and
the second translation test will be from
the third language into the competition
language
duration 90 minutes each scoring on 80
points each you need to obtain at least
40 out of 80. but this time just meeting
the passcore will certainly not be
enough you will need a higher marks
because both marks will be added up
so you'll have a combined score on 160
points
and the best or scoring people will be
ranked and eventually end up on the list
of successful candidates
what is this translation test about it's
of course a translation of a legal text
you do not have any help of any material
no dictionaries or other resources are
allowed you have to translate this test
all by yourself
we will ask you to upload your diplomas
or degrees or supporting documents by
the 14th of December again midday
Luxembourg time so you will be notified
about this so make sure you don't miss
that deadline either
and then of course you will be notified
about your results and as I said the
highest ranked people after the
translation tests will be the ones
listed on this list of successful
candidates in total we have 125 divided
over these six languages
and I said this list will be handed over
to the court of justice and they will
recruit staff from this list
if you have more questions please do
read the notice of competition first it
contains all information
you need to understand this competition
and to get through it if still you have
questions for us please reach out to us
through the web form on our website and
we will be happy to answer all your
questions do also follow us on social
media where we keep you updated on these
competitions and other opportunities
that we offer
this is what I have to tell you for this
opportunity good luck with the
competition and hope to see you next
time bye bye